take out a towel to go it's I'm pretty
excited because today I've got my hands
on the little yarn Yoshi's for me
Hershey's wooly world actually nuff is
on the Amazon and they are the Japanese
imports because this game is already out
everywhere else except in North America
so unfortunately I've gotta get the
goods elsewhere they're really cute
they're so in love when I'm freaking
cute look at Budds page oh my gosh they
are so adorable
you do have to tip I like the pink one
oh and there's squishy too which is so
so squishy
okay pink pink will up next to him oh
look at them they're cute they're so
cute we got one more they come in three
color blue so I keep looking on the side
because I want to be able to make sure
their focus okay hold him up look at you
my goodness I don't know what I'm doing
okay I'm just showing them showing you
guys did you get me one I'm in love with
the Yoshi Yoshi Yoshi we've got it from
the internet
from Amazon from do she yeah this is
really troubling I can oh wow we're
really light we must avoid gust of wind
well I'm getting busy watching you okay
thanks for watching let me know all the
things you're looking forward to that's
coming out for Nintendo god I can't wait
for Mario maker September 11th September
11th where will you be at my house
playing Mario maker okay it's already in
my calendar I don't want to say that
good I think I'm gonna take them to bed
but there was really cute what if these
were real like what if these were real
and they were like hoppin around the
house like oh like eating eggs like
nummies or the fridge in other words
buddy
Yoshi Yoshi oh my god can you imagine
like this big this big maybe a little
bit bigger so I probably still on what
if they were actual real size Yoshi's
that you could ride like Mario right
Yoshi that's the future oh I just I'm
not sure how it's gonna happen evolution
I don't think it's gonna happen in our
lifetime unfortunately that is the most
Des Moines really setting that I've ever
had to come into realization that I will
never get a chance to ride a real Yoshi
I'm not gonna sleep tonight all right
I'll see you later bye I'm not gonna be
just any brownies I can assure you that
this is gonna be poo emoji brownies